hi this is a Sadashiva pie from science
mission today we have a dr sachet on and
the Panda from Salk Institute of
biological sciences with us
so he's the professor of a regulatory
biology lab dr. panda is interested in
understanding the molecular mechanism of
the biological clock in mouse model
system so the biological clock or
circadian oscillator in most organisms
coordinates behavior and the physiology
with the natural light dark cycle so his
laboratory uses genetic genomic and
biochemical approaches to identify the
genes under circadian regulation in
different organs and to understand the
mechanism of such regulation dr. panda
has won several awards to his credit and
is in the editorial board of several
journals he has also published more than
90 articles in peer-reviewed journals
like science nature cell metabolism self
reports etc so please welcome dr. panda
so welcome sign I am glad to be here so
that's it you're doing something good
great thank you
let's get going so can you please talk
about your yourself your background
education excitation excuse me yeah so
you know I have a PhD in molecular
biology and actually in during my PhD I
worked on plant circadian clock how
plants measure time and then how they
use this cloth to figure out what season
it is so that they can flower excuse me
in the right season so whether it's
summer season our winter season so then
after PhD I got interested in animal
circadian rhythms so during my postdoc
at Novartis I started working on cicada
under them send rodents and insects
and then almost 15 years ago I joined
the Salk Institute as a assistant
professor working on continue to work on
circadian rhythms and has been almost 15
years or so and now I'm a full professor
sock just talk to us about your lab lab
people yeah so my lab is at the Salk
Institute which is a very has a very
profound very interesting architecture
and the lab has nearly ten people who
work on various aspects of rhythms some
work on the molecular mechanism some
work on the how the clock senses light
and then some working on how security
and clock interacts with what when and
how much we eat and how it operates our
health
so that's briefly about the lab okay and
you know like PhD takes long time five
six years so how do you motivate these
people to get going well you know humans
are the only species who are really
curious and can and can innovate
something can imagine something can
create something and that we're doing a
PhD is that freedom to use your
imagination your creativity to create
something and I think PhD is doing the
PhD is a very interesting aspect of life
because that's when you are doing what
you are really excited about you're
doing your hobby with honest taxpayers
money so there are very few people who
have that privilege to do that so I
think people sort of think it that way
that you are really truly living the
life of a human you are imagining you're
creating stuff and at the same time you
should be grateful to the owners
taxpayers who are making it possible
yeah that's a good way to go okay in
like
like regarding the mentors like you know
like there are lots of people who
support your carrier and everybody's
many of the scientists need the support
and mentorship or coaching so can you
talk about your experience with the
mentorship
yeah means I was fortunate enough that I
had good mentors but at the same time
you know when you get a PhD you get the
PhD from the whole Institute because in
addition to your mentor there are many
professors many scientists and even your
colleagues who offer you many learning
tips and the function of the right
mentor is to facilitate that interaction
beyond the lab because inside the lab
it's natural that you will interact with
people but beyond the lab is what is the
extra stuff that you get so I was very
fortunate enough that both my PhD mentor
Steve Kay and postdoc mentor John Hagen
has given me that opportunity the
facilitator that interaction with other
people other scientists and colleagues
and essentially that way of mentoring is
a force multiplier so I didn't like that
way of mentoring that's good yep and I
know you are busy in your lab doing work
writing grants and all those things so
can you talk about your hobbies like
other interests other than research well
the thing is this is this is your hobby
I mean it's truly I mean there are very
few people who truly love their work and
so that's why I think I think of this as
my hobby when other people get to go to
work lot of them they don't like their
work and that's why they want to have
something other than work where they can
enjoy their living but as I said this is
truly kind of my hobby because as part
of this I get to travel
go to different meetings conferences
that's a part so travelling becomes part
of the hobby and you told me that like
you have been doing the circadian rhythm
from the start how come you got
interested in circadian rhythms
initially to start with well the thing
is if you look at the biomedical
research most of the biomedical research
is about what gene X does to Gen Y or
how our body interacts with something
else a micro microbe or a pollutant etc
so those interactions are very static it
doesn't have a timing component but you
and I and almost everybody who is
listening to this we all know that our
body is not the same between middle of
the day and middle of the night so
understanding that biology of timing was
a completely empty spot and biomedical
research while we clearly know that
there is a huge impact of timing for
example if it was middle of the night or
three o'clock I would have never woken
up to have this conversation but only
because it's 3 o'clock in the afternoon
I agreed to talk to you so similarly if
you think about it almost every aspect
of our behavior physiology metabolism
have a timing component and biomedical
research had essentially ignored that
for hundreds of years so I thought that
there is a big gap here and there's a
big need and that excited me and if you
think of the timing there is only one
universal timing that premiered almost
every species on this planet and that's
the 24 hours timing system or circadian
rhythm so in that way you can learn the
principle of circadian rhythm from one
simple organism and can apply to another
one and that really happens there are
very few examples in biomedical research
where you can take you can learn
principles in neuro spera
pond scum cyanobacteria or in plants and
use them in humans and in that way this
field is truly inclusive and also
transformational in this sense that you
can learn about the biology of timing
from any organism and go across species
and you have worked on circadian rhythm
and the longevity and all those things
so you are can you please say explain
you or a talk and they can go ahead and
present your work yeah I mean we can
begin with that but then if we think
about longevity loans if it is a very
interesting term it's sometimes we think
longevity is just living a long life but
I rather live after 70 or 80 year old
being completely active and fully
functional then to leave up 250 years
where half of my life is in the bed so
that's why what I am really truly
excited about is the healthy lifespan or
how many years we can leave being
healthy so in that context maybe this is
a good time to start the presentation
yeah yeah so let's do the screens here
okay yes I would like to touch upon that
longevity question and with this
provocative title that can time
restricted eating via foundation for
longevity and to put it into context if
we think of the year 1900 if in that
year a baby was born in this country
then she or he had a life expectancy of
only 45 years
and in 2018 if a baby is born that it's
likely that the person will live up to
the years of 79 years and this addition
of almost 39 40 years happened very
quickly because for almost 100,000 years
of human history humans lived somewhere
between 25 to 45 years but only in this
span of 100 years we almost doubled the
lifespan then the question is why how
did that happen the reason why that
happened was in 1900 the major cause of
death was infection or infectious
disease and biomedical research figured
out that most of these infectious
diseases are caused by microbes and that
led to cure by vaccination antibiotics
and sanitation and in fact right now if
we think of biomedical research or
Health Sciences you cannot think of
living without sanitation vaccinations
or antibiotics in fact almost every
listener to this program can imagine
them must have had at least one course
of antibiotics
must have taken a vaccine or at least
must have washed their hand this morning
and that's that profound so now that we
are living up to 79 years or 80 years in
this country is very exciting but at the
same time now the challenges are very
different because we spend almost half
of our life suffering from chronic
diseases and in fact at the age of 65
when people in this country retire
nearly 85% of Licari have two or more
chronic diseases for which they have to
take a medication or they have to be
under treatment for several years and
then the what is the cause of the
disease because as you can see if we
know the cause of the disease then then
it's for example if we know infection
was the cause of the disease and we went
to microbes and then we figured out a
solution
but here the cause of the disease
appears to be confusing it may be the
bad lifestyle choices that we make and
that the Cure is rare because even now
if somebody gets diagnosed with diabetes
then the person has to be with
medication for almost rest of the life
it's never cured so when it comes to
lifestyle and we know that bad lifestyle
cause I spent in many of the disease
then the question is what is lifestyle
and lifestyle has been very difficult to
define because it's a very fuzzy thing
it goes from mindfulness low
inflammasome diet
slaves vitamins etc and how do we go
through this and then come up with a
better lifestyle so the way we define
lifestyle is lifestyle is what when and
how much we eat sleep and move on a
daily basis as our daily habit actually
is lifestyle but most of us can relate
to what and how much we eat how it
affects health but then the concept of
when we eat or when we sleep or when we
exercise how it affects that's a
completely new concept and that concept
comes from the field of CKD and rhythm
so now I want listeners or viewers to
leave this presentation with at least 10
different takeaway message and then one
of the messages is circadian rhythm said
the ultimate science have bigger
vitality and healthy easing so the word
circadian really comes from a Latin word
which means nearly 24 hours with um's
so that means every physiology
metabolism or any biological processes
in our body that repeats itself in every
24 hours
is this Acadian rhythm and just recently
I just published a book called circadian
cold so viewers who want to learn more
about the concept or a shot then this is
a good source
so most of you know about one security
and rhythm and that's going to slave for
example almost all of us who are lucky
enough to go to bed around ten o'clock
at night we get into our deep sleep
around two o'clock between 1:00 and 2:00
in the morning and then anticipating
waking up our body will actually warm
off somewhere between four and six and
if your habitual II wake up around six o
clock then right after six o clock
between six and eight your sleep hormone
melatonin level drops trips stress
hormone cortisol level will begin to
rise that is much better digestion in
the first half of the day a lot less is
also pretty high our brain actually
functions much better in the first half
of the day the athletic performance is
much better in the early afternoon and
then in the evening another rhythm
there's the melatonin hormone levels
will begin to rise our body will cool
down and we'll go back to sleep so if
you think about having a good healthy
day then all of these processes must
happen in our body for example we should
have a good night of sleep we should
have better digestion and mine should
feel pretty good and a lot throughout
the day we should have a good bout of
exercise and when it comes to the
evening time bedtime we should feel
sleepy and that's really is the sign of
vitality and health and how is this
vitality meant and so when we say CKD
and rhythms circadian rhythms are
controlled by CKD and clocks and these
circadian clock molecular clocks I
present almost in every organ so for
example almost all of us can imagine
that there is a clock in our brain that
tells us when we should sleep or how
many hours we should sleep so
irrespective of how tired you are when
we go to sleep we typically wake up
after six seven eight or maximum ten or
twelve
hours we don't continue to sleep so the
function of the brain clock as you can
imagine is to do that process but
surprisingly in over the last 20 years
the field of circadian rhythm has also
discovered that almost every organ in
our body has its own CKD and clock and
then the function of the brain clock is
to act as a master conductor and make
sure that all these clocks are
synchronized with each other so that we
the body can produce these daily rhythms
in behavior physiology metabolism etc at
the same time this is all these internal
clocks have to be tied to the outside
world so that's mostly through light
perceived through the eye and then that
goes to the brain and what is it
interesting is although we see this
general plan and it may not appear too
impressive recent research over the last
four or five years from multiple labs
are showing that almost every harm on
every brain chemical or neurotransmitter
or enzyme and I just did shows and even
every gene in our genome rises and falls
at certain time of the day or night that
means our entire genome has its Acadian
rhythm and this came very recently from
a simple experiment done in our lab and
that came out last year in science
magazine so what we are saying here is
part of the brain called suprachiasmatic
nucleus which is the master circadian
clock there are only 20,000 neurons in
our brain and that act as master clock
and when you look at how many genes are
secure Ian's or the rise and fall are
different time of the day for example if
this is 6 a.m. in the morning there are
nearly 150 genes that rise and reach the
peak level around 8 o clock and then
they go down and then at evening there
may be only 20 or 30 genes that it is
their peak level and although they're
only hundred 50 genes in the se and that
cycle just few millimeters away
in a mother brain Center there are also
another cluster of genes that will cycle
and similarly this is another part of
lateral hypothalamus this is white
adipose tissue is one type of fat cell
this is another type of fat cells this
is very kdl fat the fat cells around our
heart this is fat in our belly kidney
cortex kidney medulla so almost every
organ that we looked at and tensor
sometimes very often hundreds of genes
that cycle and the peak at different
time of the day in fact if we continue
with sample nearly 64 different tissues
or organs and we find every organ has
its own set of cycling genes and if we
combine all of these then what we find
is almost nearly a vision in humor of
primate genome may be security and in at
least one organ so that's very profound
because just like we have the genetic
code that determines what proteins are
coded in our genes and epigenetic code
that tells in which cell or in which
organ that gene has to be torn on and
off similarly we can say that there is a
circadian code to almost every gene so
that means every gene is programmed to
turn on and off at a given time in a
given tissue and that arts another big
layer of complexity to our biological
system so then the question is how are
all these clocks synchronized with the
outside world and almost 1617 years ago
we discovered that light is a very
dominant factor that resets our clock so
when you are flipping the light switch
in your bedroom turning on light or
turning off light that is directly
affecting this master circadian clock
excuse me which are cells the conductor
of all the rhythms so flipping the light
switch literally flips hormones and
brain chemicals you know brain some
ten years ago we discovered that the
protein called melanopsin which is a
blue light sensing protein is present in
only 5,000 squiggly neurons of our eyes
and these neurons are hardwired
literally to the master clock in the
brain and what are the implications we
know that this melanopsin protein is
less sensitive to orange light because
it's a blue light sensor or moonlight
which is very dim light so as a result
our ancestors who did not have access to
electrical lighting when the evening
came and they had only candlelight or
moonlight it was not activating
melanopsin so it allowed they've sleep
hormone melatonin to rise at night and
people had better sleep and during
daytime this melanopsin is highly
activated by daylight because daylight
is rich in blue light and as a result it
synchronize brain clocks it raises a lot
Ness and reduces depression but in the
modern days as we spend most of our time
indoor then at night time when we look
at bright screens and bright light that
activates melanopsin disturbs our
circadian rhythms reduces sleep hormone
melatonin and we have poor sleep in the
daytime as we spend most of our time
indoor in low-light condition then it
misaligned CKD under them from date
night cycle reduces our alertness we
have foggy brain and if it continues for
several days then we have sleepless
night because we have too much light at
night and we have foggy brain because we
didn't sleep enough and we don't have
enough light in door and this when this
continues then we can have seasonal
affective disorders or depression and
various other brand diseases so that has
led to the idea that we can change
lighting and optimize lighting to
promote health then this is a completely
new area of research and also commercial
application that started with the
discovery simple discovery that there is
a blue light sensor in our eye and that
entrance our clock which happened almost
sixteen seven
years ago in Allah then almost six seven
years ago we made another discovery that
can be summarized as timing max healthy
food junk so for example when you think
of a healthy food served on a clean
plate you always think of that healthy
food but if we're if I serve healthy
food on a dirty plate then that becomes
not so healthy so similarly what we find
is if we are all programmed to eat say
during our regular wet wakeful hour
during the daytime or a couple of hours
into the night but if food is presented
at the wrong time in the middle of the
night then all the circadian clocks then
no longer listen to the brain clock or
the light signal they actually listen to
food so as a result eating at the wrong
time or eating at different time on
different days can disrupt these rhythms
and can disrupt all our rhythms in
behavior physiology and metabolism so
how does it relate to how does it relate
to our life we know that people who do
shift work for example pilots doctors
shift workers firefighters astronauts
they go back and forth between staying
awake during nighttime or staying awake
during their time and that disrupts
their circadian clock and in fact this
is not restricted to only few people in
the society for example our ancestor all
our ancestors they spend most of the
night in dark and most of the daytime in
bright light they had good at good
opportunity to sleep a lot of physical
activity during daytime and their
opportunity to eat was very limited it
two or three meals maximum during the
daytime only and modern rhythms are very
different almost all of us are now stuck
in dimly lit room toward day and night
we have very little sleep very little
physical activity and we have lot of
opportunity to eat and all of these
actually disrupt our circadian
so you can immediately imagine somebody
who lives this lifestyle or maybe you
yourself maybe living this lifestyle
where you don't have good sleep at night
you may be staying awake at least for
one or two nights past midnight that
disrupts our circadian clock and this is
a very disruptive lifestyle so what
happens when we leave in such a
lifestyle so living with broken
circadian rhythms bring us very close to
common chronic diseases by the same time
we should not think that common is
normal so for example nowadays a lot of
people are obese and we should not think
that that's normal because some of our
rhythms have become so disrupted for all
of us that sometimes we feel that that's
the way life is in fact if we disrupt
circadian rhythm then we can also test
what happens as a result and all of us
have experienced that just one or two
nights of staying awake or eating at the
wrong time in the middle of the night
can cause these discomforts these are
not disease but discomforts for example
irritability mood suing compromised
learning for kids fragmented sleep and
etc but if it continues for weeks months
or years then what we're finding is
almost 25 years of epidemiological
research or control clinical lab studies
or animal studies or genetic
perturbation studies are finding that
chronic circadian rhythm disruption can
lead to almost 100 different chronic
diseases starting from childhood obesity
bipolar disorders colitis obesity
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease type 2
diabetes and even various types of
cancers and all thymus disease and in
fact many of the diseases that are shown
in red here they affect more than 10
percent of the adult population in the
u.s. so that means they're at least
thirty million people suffering from
many of these chronic diseases
and the signs of circadian rhythm can
improve their health by even one person
of the target population then we are
talking about millions of people
improving their health and if we think
about longevity in this context the
reason why we are not living too long is
the cause of death in modern societies
have been many of these diseases for
example cancer heart disease number work
number among the top five causes of
disease similarly the other diseases
that are here they are among the top ten
causes of disease so that means if we
can reduce the disease burden that opens
the way for us to live longer so now how
do we improve security and rhythm so we
think of it as three different ways one
is training the circadian clock picking
of simple lifestyle habits that will
actually improve our circadian rhythms
second is clocking the drugs timing the
drugs to the right time can improve
their efficacy so we can be cured much
faster and then finally drugging the
clock
maybe we can develop drugs against
circadian clock components and those
will cure disease so among these
different aspects we focus on what is
called time restricted eating and the
concept is very simple if you think of
eating your breakfast in the morning
then as soon as we eat our breakfast a
body begins to observe some carbohydrate
from this food and it starts pouring
that carb as energy source at the same
time it stores little bit of fat and as
we continue continue our day with lunch
and dinner this process continues and
after the last meal slowly our body will
run out of carbohydrate and then during
the eating period we barely bond any fat
but after a few hours of fasting we
begin to burn little bit of stored fat
and it continues when the next day
when we eat our next meal then this
process again reverses so we begin to
run some car so now imagine if we take
these meals and spread it over a longer
time then what happens is we don't have
enough time to burn that fat because we
are always burning we always touring
some fat then we always have some
carbohydrate as glycogen so in a way and
now you can think that by eating over a
long period of time we can reduce or
dampen this daily rhythms in nutrient
metabolism at the same time there are
many processes that happen only during
the fasting period so we also deprive
our body for those processes so as a
result you can imagine that if somebody
is eating within 10 hours every day then
there is always few hours of time at
night when the person is burning fat but
if the person is eating the same number
of calories over 15 16 or maybe around
the clock then there may not be enough
time to burn some fat this is a very
simple idea so we wanted to test whether
the idea is true so almost now seven
years ago we did a very simple
experiment where we took two identical
sets of mice which were born to the same
parents in the same room with the same
genes the same microbiome and they add
the same diet the only difference
between these two groups was when they
had this food
so this mice got to eat the food
whenever they wanted so they ate half of
the food during night time and half
during day time and the second group of
mice were fed the same number of
calories as the first group but they
were trained to eat all these calories
only during the night time because my
son nocturnal they prefer to eat at
night and we continued the experiment
for several weeks almost every week we
went the food to make sure that these
two groups are eating the same number of
calories we also where demise at the end
of 18 weeks what we found is just eating
randomly anytime
made this - very obese whereas my satay
had the same number of calories within 8
to 12 hours we call it time restricted
eating they were completely lean and one
very important point here is these two
groups of pies at the same number of
calories there's no change in calories
just the timing and those obese mice
were also showing signs of many chronic
diseases that are among the top 10
causes of morbidity or death among
Western countries and what is more
exciting is two years later we took
these mice which are already sick and
then we ask them to eat all their food
within eight to ten hours and we can
reverse the disease so that was also
truly exciting because it's time
restricted eating not only prevent
disease it can also cure disease then we
asked when do people actually eat so if
you ask anyone people will say that they
eat maybe three square meals and within
10 to 12 hours between the first and
last meal but the problem is we often
forget about the smaller meals that we
randomly eat or maybe occasional eating
that we do so that's why we started a
study and in fact this is still ongoing
where anyone anywhere in the world can
go to this website called my circadian
clock dot o-r-g
and can sign up for this app that we
have developed in the lab and the app
people take pictures of their food in
the faster day we ask them to take
pictures of their anything that they ate
even if it's a handful of nuts a little
bit of here a small bite of some
vegetables everything that they had they
took pictures and then when these
pictures came to our server we line them
up along the time line and we asked
people to record their food for almost
two to three weeks so that we can also
figure out how their eating habit
changes between weekday weekend etcetera
and we called it Frida gram and you're
looking at one typical persons very
healthy person who is not a sept worker
seemingly healthy because we don't know
whether they have any condition and what
you find is this person is randomly
eating and there is not much a sign of
three meals a day in fact all these
snacks are also listed here and if we
combine all this data then we see that
person has one type of eating habit
during the weekday that's the weak tip
and then this is in the weekend so as if
the person actually goes to a different
time zone because the person delayed
breakfast which also resets our or
disturbs our circadian clock and if we
combine all this data and put it around
a clock then we feel like this is three
weeks of data this is 6 a.m. that 6 p.m.
you might think that this is an outlier
but in fact almost 156 people who were
in our study who are just regular worker
who used to work for 9:00 to 5:00
they had this random eating habit in
fact if we ask what time they ate as
expected they would eat most of them add
something around noon that's their lunch
and then most of them add something
around dinnertime around 7 o'clock but
then if we ask how many calories were in
the food although indeed midnight they
are sparse leaving those midnight
calories that food were very rich in
calories and the bottom line was almost
half of the people ate for 15 hours or
longer then the question is what is an
ideal circadian day how do we prevent
disease how do we improve health so the
way we look at an ideal circadian days
one should be in bed for eight hours we
are not asking people to sleep for eight
hours to be in bed for eight hours so
that means out of those eight hours
someone can sleep maybe somewhere
between six and a half to seven hours
which is actually the healthiest amount
of sleep for an adult and then after
waking up maybe about food for at least
one hour in the morning because this is
the hour when the sleep hormones are
going down and then they stress someone
so they wake up hormones are coming up
and this is not a good time to eat
because these hormones can interact with
food in many different ways and then
after the first bite of food one can
continue eating or can have all the
lunch and dinner within eight hours
interval or ten eleven or twelve hours
and we call it eight hours of time
reading and eleven or twelve hours of
time listed eighteen but never beyond
twelve hours so between your first meal
and last calories would be twelve hours
of course you have three to drink and
not plenty of water during this fasting
interval we also is a good idea to avoid
food and avoid bright light couple of
hours before bedtime because that can
interfere with our gut function our
stomach function or the way our insulin
is controlled glucose regulation etc so
no food for two to three hours before
bedtime at the same time it's also very
important to step outside to get some
daylight you don't have to look at the
Sun just being outside even on a cloudy
day gives us enough light plenty of
light
in fact just thirty minutes of some
physical activity or thirty minutes of
exposure to light is a great way to
reduce depression so just imagine light
is the best antidepressant we have is
plenty and it's free you just have to
step outside for a half an hour and the
question is some people ask me what
about coffee can we drink coffee the
reality is if you stand in front of a
coffee shop you'll see that 90 plus
percent of the people drink coffee with
lot of cream and sugar
so in fact most of the coffee that we
drink in this country the sweet
concoction with a little bit of caffeine
on top so in that way with coffee we
drink a lot of typical coffee with cream
and sugar has lot of calories so that's
why we ask people not to drink coffee
outside this eating window and also it's
a good idea to avoid coffee
six to seven hours before your typical
bedtime because many of us cannot break
down coffee well and having afternoon
coffee can disturb your sleep then
people ask what about coffee in the
morning and this is where there are
three exceptions if your job is on the
line so for example if you are working
for a TV station where you have to go
early in the morning and do the morning
so and it's impossible for you to stay
awake or look less sleepy so then it's
okay to have some black coffee and if it
is a safety hazard suppose say you're
doing the night shift and you woke up
here oh sorry you are going home here in
the morning or you woke up very early
and you have to go to work it's much
better to be caffeinated and write them
to be sleepy and driving and then
finally if you just can't leave without
it that's the last thing in your life
that gives you happy then maybe you can
have some black coffee between waking up
and your first gallery so then the
question is if you do this time
restricted eating then what are the
benefits so this is a review that was
published almost three years ago so this
is relatively old information but this
still holds good so that time restricted
eating can help particularly eight to
ten hours of time lacerating can help to
reduce obesity so that is reduction in
lean
sorry fat mass but the same time if you
combine it would tell the diet then at
least in mice we see the again some lean
mass or muscle mass that is better
glucose homeostasis so in that way
people who have pre-diabetes or very
early stage of diabetes may be time
mister to eating when I said I've it is
it's type-2 diabetes not type one then
they may improve their blood glucose and
they may prevent or even reverse
pre-diabetes then timeless rating
improves gut microbiome so people who
have some stomach upset and stomach
cases they may benefit from time
deteriorating
in fact we do see a lot of people who
have acid reflux they seem to benefit
from that so it's not that everybody
will benefit but it's a good thing to
try then and preclinical animal studies
have shown that time mister eating can
reduce arrhythmia and improve cardiac
function in fact it can reduce your
easing of heart so the heart functions
much like a much younger heart the
entire cherating reduces chronic
inflammation so tissue inflammation goes
down people actually feel less pain in
their joints and maybe they can go for a
little bit more exercise
there is definitely reduced fibrosis and
steatosis of fat deposit in liver and
nearly one third of adults in the US
have fatty liver disease so this is
something that we are very excited if it
is feasible for many of these people who
have only stays of fatty liver disease
they can try I'm reiterating and
hopefully they will improve their
condition or maintain it so that it
doesn't get too bad there are many
studies coming out now that people who
eat within a short shorter interval
maybe 11 hours
they're all food within 11 or less
number of hours then they have reduced
risk for breast cancer and also there
are new studies showing prostate cancer
risk also goes down by 20 25 percent at
least in animal studies we do see
cholesterol levels drop this may take
slightly longer for humans because of
obvious differences between how animals
and humans we metabolize cholesterol we
also find a lot of people who do time
mister eating they report their sleep
quality goes up some people find it very
easy to fall asleep some people say
their sleep the number of hours they
sleep also increases and in terms of
muscle at least in animals and insects
what we find is mice that to time list
rating they have much better endurance
they can go on treadmill for a long time
and insects that do time - everything
they can fly even into their late old
days
so in that way what we find is timeless
rating can prevent or reverse a man has
better managed many of these chronic
diseases that are in red here or many of
these diseases that have been the major
cause of disability morbidity or death
among modern population so that's why we
strongly believe that this can be one
simple habit one can incorporate into
their daily lifestyle at least try to
eat everything within 12 hours and if
you can make it better than maybe 10
hours and at least that will prevent
some of these diseases so that we can
are several years of healthy life to our
life thank you
okay I think you are interesting to look
at the components how do you manage your
food habits and all those things and
sleep habits so I have one question yeah
like people like it it is possible to do
that but there are like as you know the
doctors nurses they have like six months
or four months of night duty and all
those things so how do they manage that
like I mean like like is there like for
these genes and all those things do they
get adjusted with the time if you do
some of the things in a certain way yeah
I mean if you are working the night
shift and you are essentially your body
is thinking that it's in a different
time zone so people who work the night
shift continuously and rest during the
daytime maybe they can eat all their
food during night time because that
becomes their biological day and the
challenge is in the weekend when they
try to come back and socialize then that
becomes a bigger challenge so that's why
it has been a little bit difficult for
shift workers another thing is shift
work is not just one type of work or one
schedule of work so for example some
shift workers may be working 24 hours
saved some to 12 hour shift some to
eight hour shift and even those who are
doing eight to ten hours of saved or
twelve hours of saved that ship may
rotate in every way
in every month or in few months so there
is so much heterogeneity in shift work
that is really hard and the way I look
at it is we created shift work without
knowing the relevance of circadian
rhythm or how bad it is for our health
and now that you are learning about how
Baird is sipped work may be slowly the
public and also the policymakers will
think more clearly about it and come up
with certain regulations for example
maybe the shift if you are on night
shift then you should be on night shift
for a couple of months at least so that
your body are just - that before you
come back - another shift and similarly
one should not be changed from day to
night shift within the same week so
these are some of the policies that we
feel that should come to force this is
just imagine several decades ago when we
did not know what is the bad effect of
asbestos and lead we had built many
buildings with asbestos and lead and
once we knew the bad effect then it make
it took almost few decades to change
that so similarly now that we know what
is the bad effect of circadian
disruption among shift workers hopefully
that will slowly trigger the public
workers themselves to begin demanding so
there are two aspects one is timing the
drugs so the drugs that are already in
market not force akkadian clogs but your
blood pressure or for glucose regulation
etcetera
there are some studies showing that
certain blood pressure medications if
they're taken in the evening they work
much better in reducing blood pressure
than the same medication taken in the
morning so similarly there are
medications to reduce joint pain
arthritis pain although the pain is more
severe in the morning if the drug is
taken at the night then it has much
better effect on reducing pain in the
morning
so there's several examples now
and similarly actually this field which
is now called chrono medicine or timing
up medicine it started almost three four
decades ago when people figured out that
some of the cancer drugs to treat breast
cancer worked much better in the morning
or evening so it depends on the drug and
depends on the target of the drug so
this is a completely new area of
medicine but just imagine that among the
top ten best-selling drugs in the u.s.
for every person these drugs benefit
there are 3 to 20 people for whom the
drug actually doesn't work so if we can
improve efficacy of these drugs even by
10 to 15 percent by timing them properly
then we are talking about millions of
people who will benefit and know mostly
from these drugs and they can cure their
disease so that's the impact of the
future in fact of chrono medicine and
finally when it comes to security and
clock and drugs this is an emerging
field this is a very new area and just
recently just last year we published a
way for that sure that many types of
cancers do not have a circadian clock
they have a dysfunctional clock so then
the question is if you reactive at the
clock what happens
so we reactivated kind of you can think
of reactivating a clock with an agonist
for one of the clock component and that
actually met the cancer cells
susceptible to death so the cancer cells
die with this drug clock drug but not
the normal cells because the normal cell
so used to security and rhythm that
they're fine but then the cancer cells
who have lost track of timing they don't
have the timing discipline you bring
back the clock then they die so I think
that's a very exciting area that some of
the top drug might be very effective in
treating inflammation cancer etc release
happens more during this time so that
you can like major kind of metabolic
aspects like secretion of hormones and
or absorption like for example kidney
like you have more like absorption of
minerals during certain period of time
is there any work done on - because that
is one of the I think key component of
the whole area if you want to monitor or
do the drug gets a ten point for
different things
is there any much work done on that yeah
almost that's why I say almost happy
hormone in our body has a CKD in rhythm
they rise and fall at certain time and
in fact insulin releases much better in
the first half of the day but is not so
well in the evening or late night so in
that way just timing your carbohydrates
for to the first half of the day is a
good thing to do but when it comes to
insulin releasing drugs for example in
cretons or glp-1 drugs there is not much
work done on what time this should be
administered but with this CKD under
them getting more and more recognized
and I'm sure there are some clinical
trial going on right now somewhere in
the world to test that so similarly for
kidney function for gut function almost
in every area now there are works going
on
it's been really nice knowing you
knowing your work I really appreciate
you coming and spending your time on a
science hangout and thank you so much if
you have anything something new coming
up you can just shoot me an email we can
have another hangout on some new work
any time thank you so much
thank you so that's it I'm happy to be
here and I'm looking forward to more and
more source from your site thank you so
much